[Música]
el presidente de Venezuela Nicolás
Maduro prometió que sí habrá elecciones
presidenciales en 2024 unos comicios
cruciales para un país que lucha por
recobrar su vigencia ahora menos
castigado por la comunidad internacional
después de una demostrada imposibilidad
de derrocar al chavismo
Perdón Pese a que es un movimiento
condenado por la crisis social económica
y de Derechos Humanos se mantiene la
oposición siempre fragmentada en la
última década espera enviar a las urnas
a un único candidato vamos a realizar el
análisis de este tema y para ello nos
acompaña Ana Milagros Parra Ana
bienvenida a las 24 Hola Muchas gracias
por la invitación Buenos días
Ana hablemos primero de la
inhabilitación por 15 años impuesta a
María Corina Machado Qué opinión le
merece esto
Bueno hay que tener en cuenta que la
mayoría de los candidatos fuertes en
estas primarias ya están inhabilitados
como Freddy superlano y Enrique capriles
la inhabilitación de María Corina es
totalmente inconstitucional ni siquiera
Es legal si tú ves la sentencia que hizo
que María Corina esté inhabilitada esta
vez por 15 años no tiene ningún sustento
legal lo hicieron arbitrariamente para
que ella no pudiese una traba más para
que no pudiese postularse para la
presidenciales de 2024 ya que María
Corina tenía una inhabilitación de unos
pocos meses hace años y por medio
totalmente arbitrario la inhabilitaron
ahora para Simplemente porque la
identificaron como una amenaza para las
posibles comicios y están poniendo todas
las trabas institucionales posibles para
que ella no se Lance y para que la
oposición no logre unirse y
cuestionar su estratégicamente y así
representar una amenaza para el chavismo
bueno precisamente este miércoles fue el
debate de Los precandidatos por la
oposición para estas primarias
independientes que han anunciado Cuáles
son los perfiles más destacados
Bueno yo ayer estuve en el debate Y la
verdad la candidata más destacada es
María Corina porque es la que tiene más
aceptación cuando vemos las encuestas y
el siguiente era Benjamín roseo Pero él
se salió de las primarias quiero
destacar que él es un perfil que No
necesariamente se la calificaría como
oposición como tal porque es una parte
de la oposición que posiblemente esté
cooptada por el chavismo otro de los
perfiles que se alzan un poco sería el
de Freddy superlano que es de voluntad
popular incluso de esa solorza no pero
cuando ves en las encuestas y la
aceptación de las personas no tienen
comparación con María Corina Machado a
pesar de que hubo varias sorpresas en el
debate la verdad se vio un ambiente de
unidad y de cooperación entre ellos pero
no hay ninguno que le llegue cerca a
María Machado en términos de campaña en
términos de las encuestas y de
aceptación de la población bueno sin
embargo esta sensación de unidad es algo
que está por verse después de años en
los que se ha demostrado una y otra vez
como está de fragmentada la oposición en
el país ahora quisiera preguntarle por
otro tema que preocupa de Cara a estos
anunciados comicios de 2024 y es la
renuncia masiva el 15 de junio de
miembros del Consejo Nacional electoral
que salieron de sus cargos seis de ellos
posteriormente otros dos renunciaron
poco poca información se dio sobre esto
simplemente fue aceptada la renuncia por
la asamblea nacional y aquí le pregunto
Pues Cuáles son las preocupaciones sobre
la independencia en los comicios que
estas renuncias generan bueno son
preocupaciones que por parte de la
oposición y toda la sociedad civil
Siempre han estado porque desde hace
muchos años en Venezuela no hay unas
elecciones libres con garantías
electorales incluso eh la revisión de
observación de la de la ONU vino y dio
algunas recomendaciones y todavía no no
afirma que en Venezuela puede haber
comicios electorales libres como
mencionas lo del cne es una de las más
demostraciones de que el chavismo o en
este caso el madurismo Busca manipular
todas las instituciones están Bajo su
control y crearlas a su manera para que
sean mucho más controlables y más
cómodas para ellos ya ese ese consejo
nacional electoral tenía dos rectores
opositores pero no hubo ninguna
discusión y fue de un día para otro que
mandaron a los porque eso sí eso fue una
decisión Del ejecutivo que los rectores
chavistas renunciaran y los dos
opositores todavía no tenemos
explicaciones de por qué renunciaron
pero hicieron unos días después para qué
Para crear un consejo nacional electoral
mucho más cómodo para ellos para unos
posibles elecciones presidenciales
porque saben que pueden significar Un
aumento de presión por parte de la
oposición para el chavismo Así que lo
que hicieron fue vamos a crearlo de
nuevo y a poner una traba más para las
primarias Porque es importante esto
porque las primarias opositoras estaban
buscando la cooperación técnica la
asistencia técnica por parte del cne que
no la habían dado respuestas estaban
todos esperando para que las primarias
Se podrían realizar por los métodos
normales y que el Consejo Nacional
electoral los apoyara y cuando pasó esto
simplemente la Comisión Nacional de las
primarias dijo necesitamos hacer las
autogestionadas porque no hay manera que
el cne nos apoye todo lo contrario está
buscando dinamitarlas y que haya
muchísimos obstáculos para que no se
lleven a cabo claro y de ahí este
término de las primarias independientes
de la oposición Lo cierto es que el 10
de enero del 2025 Tendría que haber un
nuevo presidente en el Palacio
presidencial Cuál es la apuesta del
oficialismo Por otra parte para la
presidencia
la puesta del oficialismo evidentemente
quedarse en el poder con Nicolás Maduro
como candidato pero algo que siempre me
gusta de esta destacar es que hablar de
Venezuela en el largo plazo y sí largo
plazo 2024 y 2025 es bastante arriesgado
porque las cosas y el la dinámica
política puede cambiar de hoy para
mañana no O sea antes del debate
Pensamos la posición no tiene ningún
ningún espacio para que pueda
encontrarse ella misma y en el debate
nos dieron otras cosas por parte del
oficialismo yo busco en quedarse en el
poder y algo importante es decir gané
unas elecciones y así la comunidad
internacional legitime o digan más
maduro es el presidente en contraste lo
que pasó en los años anteriores donde
todos les decían que no era presidente y
teníamos Un gobierno interino y teníamos
un Nicolás Maduro que estaba luchando
por legitimidad supuestamente y es algo
que se está manejando desde desde el
madurismo es hace unas mega elecciones a
no solamente las presidenciales sino
también las regionales y las municipales
e incluso la de la asamblea porque así
les hace muchísimo más difícil la
oposición poder coordinarse para
enfrentar electoral tan grande y es
importante decir que eso sería
totalmente ilegal no se debería hacer
una mega elección porque no son los
tiempos estipulados pero vemos en 2024
todavía incierto por parte de la
oposición pero con Nicolás Maduro que va
a buscar la reelección para así
legitimarse pues Anaya Nos quedamos sin
tiempo pero le agradezco porque abre el
camino esto en la preparatoria de las
elecciones de Venezuela es Ana Milagros
Parra politóloga consultora política y
también analista de políticas públicas
que tenga un feliz día Muchas gracias
agradecimiento para nuestros
televidentes que nos han acompañado
hasta aquí pero quédense con nosotros
hacemos una pausa y ya volvemos con más
[Música]